i remember the first time i was able to
have conversations about anime with
other people and that was just
so liberating for me yeah that i had
spent
all of these years enjoying this medium
but have literally nobody to talk to it
about yeah and then i made youtube
videos to be like okay
if i can't have anyone to talk to about
i'm just gonna talk to the void
and hopefully someone will listen and i
remember having the some of the first
genuine conversations
online because it had to be online back
then um about shows that i liked and it
just
i just felt free yeah because um
yeah i don't know who your first friend
in uh in like the anime youtube sphere
was
for me it was uh probably horden reviews
and
the people from potaku were going going
way back then
i think mine might have been misty
you're
you're dismissed i think i don't even
know i mean except for the one in jail
i don't think there's anyone else i
would categorize
like a lot of them were just like
fleeting you know mutuals
you know yeah i'd say you guys probably
the first proper friends that i
i made outside that first you know yeah
because it was it was strange for me
because i'm the complete opposite when
it comes to
my friend circle on youtube where you
would think that
i would be very quick to bond with other
antitubers
once starting an anime youtube channel
yeah weirdly enough for like the first
two years or so i was only friends with
gaming youtubers
yeah but that's also because i was doing
a lot of gaming stuff alongside stuff
and and i think it honestly might have
been misty that was the first like
proper anna tuber
and that was when i discovered this
entire community of antitubers i was
like oh my god i'm not the only one yeah
there are other people who do this stuff
as well and then that's when
i kind of to drift away from more of the
gaming stuff and focus on what my
channel was actually about
yeah yeah i remember i i realized we get
comments sometimes that are like
me listening to the podcast and it's
like that guy sitting next
because i remember i was doing my a
levels i remember listening to paul taku
actually oh i remember i used to listen
to it yeah
i would do my i remember i have this
distinct memory of you guys arguing i
don't know
what but i was doing a lot of things
yeah i was doing my math a levels
i was and i remember just listening to
it and i was like man and i want to like
be in that talk friends i want to like
talk to friends about anime because i
never
even at that point when i was like what
like 17 i still had no one to talk to
you about anime yeah
and uh i didn't really make friends
until university but
i got banned from my uh anime uh
club facebook group because they were
talking about like housing abridged and
i was like oh [ __ ] i voiced in there i
said in the comments i was like oh yeah
i voiced
it and then they banned me they thought
i was lying
because they were like they were like
why would someone in our university
you know first year be voicing in
helsinki and then i went to the club and
i explained
that like it's like two months later
yeah i i happen to go there anyway
and i was like yeah can you like unban
me from the club i don't know why you
guys banned me and they're like oh we
don't know i'm like i know i know you
[ __ ] know why
we can't have someone having clouts yeah
i do i i
was in that group for like a year and i
made one comment about that i got
immediately banned
[ __ ] you swansea
yeah they were like nope no clout in
this club
so you joined the anime club in
university then i joined i paid the two
two pound a year membership and then all
they did was watch ghibli movies
and like that's all they did i like this
i joined the anime club my universe was
the biggest mistake
it's like it's weird because it's like a
mixture of like
it's a mixture of people who like don't
really care about anime and like one or
two people who are way too into it or
into really different niches so
yeah i felt like i don't know i couldn't
really talk with none of them watch the
same [ __ ] i watched
yeah um and it was the same with gaming
like the gaming club in my uni was like
supposed to be
gaming and it was orange magic the
gathering
well i mean it's type of gaming it's
this type of game you think a gaming
club
yeah yeah they're diverse was like well
guess i'm not joining any clubs in unis
brony club it is